hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the morphe
saga
and uh we are uh going to show a
brilliant game between paul charles
murphy and stanley kipping
and uh before we check out the game uh
we
left it off with the morphe saga we left
off the morphe saga uh by
morphe and island annihilating henry
bird
and someone mentioned in the comments
that uh maybe for those of you who are
new to chess maybe it's uh
maybe it's wrong to portray henry bird
in a way that he just lost to paul
morphy because he was a brilliant player
himself and he achieved countless
victories
so i do feel it's very important to
mention that
but now as i said in the previous video
here is a very very short part
uh well not not even a page from
lawson's book on morphe
just so you know uh word by word on
what's happening
next so here uh where we left it off
morphe defeated of course uh
henry bird and then it says accompanied
by edge morphy left london thursday
august 26
by the midday train and upon arriving in
birmingham
i was enthusiastically received mr avery
president of the birmingham chess club
introduced him to the members of the
association as and as edge relates
the cheers with which he was received uh
where such as seldom
came from others than englishmen morphy
advanced up the room without the
slightest embarrassment
although his reception was as unlooked
for as
it was flattering saint aman who was
present wrote a brilliant account
uh of the meeting to the uh paris
journal esport
uh he said of morphe his walk is that of
a king and he advances through the crowd
of strangers like a monarch receiving
homage from his court
and that evening mr avery arranged a
little contest and this is the little
contest that we were mentioning
and if you remember in the previous
video or if you if you're just joining
us i will put a link to the entire
morphe saga so you can watch all the
videos and get acquainted with mr morphy
uh he said that he will he he will be
late to the birmingham
chess meeting on purpose because it
would be too hard for him not to enter
the tournament if he had the opportunity
so he had to be late for it
and uh uh unfortunately the only two
games morphy will play in birmingham are
against this gentleman here and
uh tomorrow after after this uh clash
against stanley keeping
uh he will play some blindfold games but
that's that's it he's not going to play
any serious games here
uh in case you were wondering so without
further ado let's check it out as i know
you guys are eager to check out the game
uh as you've seen in the
thumbnail all the action that's going to
happen so e4 by morphe we have e5
sorry about that uh with knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to c4 uh the
the italian game is on the board and
bishop to c5 and now of course
as anyone who ever uh reaches this
position should play b4 uh morphe goes
for
40 evans gambit i'm not going to try and
trick you guys because it's in the
thumbnail
so bishop captures on b4 keeping accepts
the the gambit and now c3
challenging the bishop bishop to a5 and
now d4 since we made a tutorial on how
to play the evens gaming i'm sure uh you
guys
know all of this he captures on d4 and
morphe castles now and here
d6 so this is uh properly being played
uh only the bravest of gentlemen capture
on c3 but
you know you do not want to do that and
queen to b3 now that the bishop is here
the knight cannot come to a5 you go
after the f7 pawn
and here keeping defense with queen to
f6 the pawn is now defended
and while most people would just capture
on d4 and claim they have a better
position
morphe continues in great style and
pushes e5
and here uh the the the really fun part
uh starts happening so here
uh uh keeping's queen is under attack
and he needs to do something about it so
he captures the d
captures on e5 and now not uh c
captures on d4 c captures on d4 is very
interesting
because morphe already played this game
a year prior to this uh but he had it
with the black pieces where thompson
captured c captures on d4
and morphe was able to win this game
with black but now morphe plays it with
the white pieces so morphe knows quite a
lot of theory on the evan's gambit
uh much like yourself so rook to e1 now
uh putting more pressure on the c5 pawn
and now bishop back to b6 here
you should just play knight h6 and
castle now you could also go knight here
but bishop to g5 could be a bit annoying
so
just knight h6 castle and you know you
you are very happy with black
however here bishop to b6 was played
preparing this knight a5 to go after the
queen and the bishop
uh and also add some support on d4 but
now comes bishop to g5 by morphe we have
queen to f5 and now
knight captures on e5 so a temporary
peace sacrifice of course you cannot uh
capture the bishop that would be just
weird
uh because the knight threatens all
sorts of nasty discoveries and also
bishop captures on f7 so
everything will be hanging here so the
knight needs to be captured knight
captures and e5 is played
and now comes f4 challenging the knight
that's now pinned by the rook
i will mention in 80 60 uh four years
after this game was played there is a
game where
queen to b5 check was played but it
doesn't give white all that much because
after black blocks this
you can trade queens but it's not uh
it's not all that impressive black is
very happy with this position he's just
gonna block check and
even though white can win another pawn
it's nothing serious for black black is
up upon and very happy with his uh
well not the development but once he
gets a few moves in he's going to be
perfectly fine
so instead morphe plays f4 and it is as
of move 13 that the disposition has
never been reached again
so let's see what happens here the
knight is under attack rook captures on
e5 would win the queen
so of course skipping has to do
something about this and he does he
plays d
captures on c3 and this is very
very uh tricky uh because yes
you do check the the white king however
there was the incredible f6 but
uh f6 is such a difficult move to
calculate it's just i mean try
try and work out this position by
yourself if you want to it's really
not just fun it's really really
difficult because here
the the the strongest line would be
bishop captures and g8
just grabbing a piece but now king of f8
unpinning
and attacking a piece here and now we
would have f captures an e5
f captures and g5 and now of course you
don't want to lose the bishop so you
bring it back and now
g6 and black is actually very happy here
uh because
uh it seems like you're about to lose a
queen with rook to f1 but if white
actually plays this just d3
and e3 is such a strong move not only
does it deliver check to the white king
it also blocks the bishop's defense of
the rook
so here either king h1 and queen
captures an f1 checkmate
or you have to give up the queen for the
bishop here black gives up the queen for
the rook and
black will be much better captures
captures and after bishop captures here
you're not only up the exchange you're
also up upon so
black is completely winning uh here so
that's what happens if
f6 is played here black doesn't win
black only wins if white goes for the
silly rook f1 move but it's a fight so
here instead
d captures on c3 check uh by keeping
checking the white king and now morphy
happily goes king h1 so he doesn't have
to worry about that anymore
and now bishop to d4 adding more defense
to the knight here with
some ideas of c2 the rook might come
under attack and so on
so morphy simply captures on c3 and here
uh
we have king to f8 king to f8 just i'm
pinning and saying i'm perfectly fine
here
but he's not so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the winning
move for
for morphe that well i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
absolutely strongest queen to a3 which
is not the move morphy played morphy
played rook 8 to d1 which is the second
strongest move
uh but uh morphy probably saw okay this
is winning so i don't have to
search anymore but we're just gonna show
queen to a3 because i know most of you
found queen to a3
so you know let's just show it this uh
delivers
check to the black king now of course if
you go back then just rook captures uh
here and
you know the the entire position falls
apart or even knight to b5 is an idea
going after the bishop going after c7
a lot of possibilities here so here you
would have to block it with c5
and only now rook captures an e5 so this
is
uh beautiful stuff bishop captures and
now you've removed the defender of the
c5 pawn queen captures here
with check and now uh you know anything
is possible the best defense for black
is king e8 but
then knight to d5 and it's just complete
madness
if b6 challenging the white queen knight
c7 check
now you pick up uh the knight with the
bishop bishop captures and al basha b5
check and black is uh
completely destroyed the king has no
squares to go to and if you block check
with the bishop
now you can finally capture the queen as
this bishop is pinned you cannot
you cannot capture so this is what
happens uh if queen to a3
checked but morphy saw that rook a to d1
was enough so this is what he played and
now
uh keeping needs to find a a nice
defensive resource so he goes for it
with the knight captures on c4 and make
no mistake uh these gentlemen are
playing some
top level chess here like this is uh the
entire game is pretty much
equal all the time so here at knight
captures on c4
queen captures and now we have uh bishop
to e6 with an attack on the queen if you
try and save this bishop
uh you're just going to lose terribly
for example if you try and save the
bishop to f6
rook d5 and the queen has nowhere to go
because
your your main problem is if you if you
deliver check along this diagonal
black always has this c5 move and the
queen is guardian now you just cut off
the queen's defense of the c5 square
and that's it whatever black plays you
just win the game queen c5 check
and now whatever 97 rook d8 checkmate
so here uh instead of this uh attempt to
save the bishop we have bishop to e6
attacking the queen
and sacrificing the bishop i mean you
have nothing better
and now f6 and uh you know
uh imagine this we still have a fight so
uh keeping is really holding his own
against morphy
uh with knights to e4 morphe now offers
a bishop on g5 but capturing it
wouldn't be possible because here again
queen captures a queen to be for check
and now uh you you don't really have
anything good 97 and now knight captures
on g5
with a double attack on the bishop if
you move the bishop then it's a double
attack on the knight
so black is completely busted here so
here uh one
last attempt b6 is played uh and
okay now morphy goes for knight to g3 he
attacks the queen
uh we have queen to c5 offering a queen
trade and now
after all of this madness morphy says
all right now it's time to trade queens
with
czech so captures captures and rook
captures on e6 so
winning back is peace and uh uh sorry
winning by winning the piece now we have
f captures on g5 winning back the piece
and the g6 and here it seems like uh
it's perfectly fine for black because
not only is the e
material equal but he's also up upon but
black has no moves here morphe just
plays h4
and black is uh without any any good
moves
uh you could try something like rook to
b8 but it doesn't really
improve improve your position you
shouldn't really move your rooks away
from the back ring because then morphy's
rook comes to the back rank and
it's just terrible so here for example
if you try knight the e7
just rook f1 check and now it's just
terrible if you move the king then you
lose the knight if you play knight f5
then just captures captures and captures
completely busts open the position and
if you try something like this then you
just lose the knight
as it spinned and you just brought
another attacker to the knight
so here after h4 king the f7 is played
but now
rook to e5 and again not not a lot for
black to play here
h6 is played but now knight to e4 we
have captures and captures this comes
with
check king f6 and now rook to e6 with
check and now it doesn't matter where
the black king goes if king g7 then just
rook d7
check king can go here knight f7 check
uh checks the king
forks the forks the rook but also it's
uh it's gonna be
uh checkmate very very quickly from here
on so here after this rook to e6 check
we have kinked the f5 but now it's
just a very nice mate in four uh rook to
d5
with check and now uh it's the uh you
know just hunting
hunting the black king king f4 rookie
for check and after this rookie for
check on move 30
stanley keeping resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
so here uh once you move the king king
g3
it's just rook d3 check king to f3 and
akin to f2 and now rook to f3 will be
checkmate so of course
uh uh this uh there was no need to uh
you know pl
play this out uh he just resigned here
and what a victory for
for paul morphy who wins his first game
upon arriving to
birmingham and uh like i said we're
gonna show one more game against
skipping uh where he has the white
pieces and morphe is black
and i'm not gonna you know spoil it but
uh
again we're gonna see a very nice
opening uh with
you know with with white uh so
that's the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it it took us some time to get
back to the morphe saga because morphe
saga and
all the other sagas that i'm doing are
something that i do
when there aren't any events currently
being played in the world and
there are so many events now so morphe
saga is on hold most of the times but we
will always get back to it and we will
finish it no worries
uh so yeah once again i do hope you guys
enjoyed it and that little part from
lawson's book
just to you know uh improve on your vast
knowledge
uh i would like to thank christoph
schmidt sadati
nicolas thomas sikorski and eric fennell
for his uh
friend sam wilson who wishes him a happy
birthday
so and i of course join in with with the
congratulations
uh so yeah uh that's uh that's it guys i
do hope you enjoyed it uh as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
morphe saga here checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday